dans la gestion de cette guerre cotée
occidentale il est absolument primordial
pour la Maison Blanche et les principaux
leaders européens d'étudier ensemble les
mesures qu'il faut continuer à prendre
dans cette guerre qui promet désormais
de durée on l'a compris mais je dirais
que cette coordination indispensable
commence par la conduite des mesures
déjà prises par l'Union européenne et
les États-Unis on en reviendra pas sur
les sanctions financières qui vont
continuer de s'abattre sur la Russie
avec les effets escomptés c'est-à-dire
concrètement une asphyxie progressive de
l'économie russe et en filigrane une
stimulation de la contestation anti
Poutine dans l'opinion russe bien sûr et
pourquoi pas jusque dans son entourage
même si cela est extrêmement difficile à
mesurer au moment où nous parlons il est
beaucoup question ici à Washington de
mesurer la fidélité de la garde
rapprochée de Vladimir Poutine a
commencé par Sergueï son ministre de la
Défense mais également son chef
d'état-major des armées c'est un sujet
qui va animer le dialogue
dans la réunion que vous venez d'évoquer
mais ce qui est également au cœur de la
coordination entre pays membres de
l'OTAN c'est l'aide direct apporter à
l'Ukraine cette fois et cartons d'emblée
l'aide humanitaire même si elle est
centrale elle constitue un sujet en soi
mais c'est l'aide militaire qui a mesure
que les jours passent se révèle
considérables et en constante
augmentation pour seul exemple on
considère que depuis le début du conflit
près de 70 000 missiles antichard ou
solaires sont entrés en Ukraine ce sont
les chiffres du Pentagone en provenance
du Royaume-Uni d'Allemagne est bien
entendu des États-Unis à ce rythme ça
signifie concrètement que bientôt la
totalité des combattants Ukrainiens
qu'il s'agisse de militaires ou même de
groupes d'autodéfense sera équipé d'un
système d'armes capable d'abattre un
hélicoptère russe à basse altitude par
exemple ou de détruire un char la
question de la suprématie aérienne est
également un sujet et là aussi il y a un
piège pour le bloc occidental quels sont
les lignes rouges à ne pas franchir pour
que Vladimir Poutine ne considère jamais
que les États-Unis ou l'Europe sont
directement et militairement surtout
engagés dans la guerre ce qui
rappelons-le ferait franchir un nouveau
stade un nouveau cap au conflit si les
avions de combat par exemple même
pilotés par des Ukrainiens venait à
décoller du territoire de l'Union
Européenne si des groupes de combattants
volontaires venus de toute l'Europe
comme on sait que c'est le cas ce voyait
équipé et entraîné en Pologne ou en
Roumanie par exemple avant d'aller
combattre en Ukraine cette implication
de l'Occident pourrait faire réagir
Moscou dans une direction que même les
plus pessimistes ici à Washington refuse
même d'évoquer tant les conséquences
pourraient être lourdes